[Music]
so science the sciences are always
revisable it's quite astonishing when we
look back into the past how different
the views the quite well defended views
and quite successful views of people in
the past were from the views that we
have today so science does change a lot
now
some people see in that grounds for
doubt but I like many other philosophers
would want to say that no what we see
here is a considerable progression it's
that the ideas of the older generation
get developed extended and refined in
our newer views and so it seems to me
that what's the essence of science is
that it's never final although it's
perfectly reasonable for the scientists
at any given time to treat what they've
got very strong evidence for as if it
were the final truth because they know
from reflecting on the historical
development of the sciences that's a
very good way of getting to the views
that will eventually supersede the views
that they now have so you can think
about it if you like as a process in
which taking very seriously the ideas
that you now have after they've been
subjected to all sorts of rigorous
testing and rigorous reflection and then
trying to build on those leads you to
better and better views that give you
more and more predictive power control
over the natural world and more success
in the ways in which you want to
intervene in various aspects of the
world a lot of people are worried about
various claims that get made I mean in
the case of climate science what seems
to me to be the case is that people
quite naturally here the climate science
consensus as a very powerful warning
something that might incline them to
change their views and change the ways
in which they live
they want to know perfectly reasonably
whether the evidence is sufficiently
strong so that they should perhaps
sacrifice things that you know they're
used to enjoying and used to doing so I
think there's a reasonable form of
skepticism here but any analogy with a
sort of arm yesterday it was this today
it's that tomorrow it's going to be
something else approach to this seems to
me completely unfounded climate science
is built on views about the atmosphere
that have been developed very
successfully and in a very rigorous way
from the 19th century to the present
there are any doubt about the mechanisms
of the greenhouse effect there isn't
really any doubt about the evidence
behind the consensus that says that we
have contributed enormously to the
warming effects that are now becoming
apparent not only in the present but
also from the record of the Earth's
average temperature so all of that is as
well-founded as other things that people
take for granted that science tells them
like that water is h2o like the law of
falling bodies like the fact that the
earth is round and so on and so forth
there's no more reason to be skeptical
about the basic consensus of climate
science than there is about any of those
other things now when it comes to making
very specific predictions about where
particular catastrophes are likely to
come in the next decades that's
extraordinarily difficult and on that
all we can do is to try to simulate the
Earth's climate and how it's changing
and to arrive at good predictions for
the future and where we get a lot of
overlap in various ways of are trying to
figure out the dynamics of the Earth's
climate then we can be reasonably sure
that that's something that is likely to
happen so some of the forecasts about
the future rising sea level levels much
more frequent he
waves much bigger storms really very
serious dangers for the habitability of
some parts of the world droughts all of
that sort of stuff in general is very
very well supported by the evidence can
we say for sure how many heat waves
there are going to be within the
continental United States between 2050
and 2060 no we can't what we can say is
that there's a really high probability
of a lot of difficult disastrous events
that are going to challenge future
generations and as we deal with it now
we can't say for example how much the
temperature of the earth is going to
rise by 2100 but one thing that's really
important to understand here is that
2100 isn't some magical moment I mean
it's not really going to matter that
much if the temperature rises say four
or five degrees Celsius if that comes in
2100 or whether it comes in 2120 or
whether it comes in 2150 or whether it
comes in 2200 that's going to be a real
disaster for human beings on our planet
because five degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial temperatures is a world
in which there's no ice whatsoever and
in which you've got reptiles have able
to live you know within both polar
circles it's that hot that would be a
world in which lots of the Earth's
surface but become quite uninhabitable
for us
so we're going to do something about it
and the evidence for that seems to me
extremely strong so I think the the
reasonable skepticism with which I began
the idea that you know people if they
have to change their ways want to know
whether there's a good reason for it
that's perfectly understandable but if
they looked at the climate science
seriously and the evidence for it they
would see what the tremendous risks to
the future are
[Music]
you